quick to duck is coming to netflix
pay-per-view walmart redbox are all
those separate deals or is that all
through sort of one distributor yeah
that's the Wonder scimitar yeah and so
you know what was like the the first
things you had to do to sort of set up
these deals I really reacted the film I
did a whole new headed up a film well I
went and had a meeting with the
distributor you know and signed a
contract after I had looked at her you
know and then the work started I you
know as far as what the work that needed
to be done on my end which was more than
I imagined it was but I learned so much
when I got here you know and so I had
they told me that I needed to put the
name in the first five minutes for the
television people to see it instantly so
they'll go buy it and and there they
couldn't figure out a way to do it and
they said if you can figure out a way to
make this work it'd be better so I got a
hold of it and I did another edit of it
were I was able to do that but then I
went like oh my god I really now I
really want to do something different to
this film I readded the whole first half
of the movie and it is what I've been
thinking about at night keep me up at
night saying I should have done that I
should have done that but I didn't
because I was so frustrated from
spending so much time on editing that
you know there's so much work you know
it's so much work for one person to
teach themselves and to do that and then
to do it I just wanted to be done I
wanted to be done you know but
thankfully I was smart enough to listen
to my distributor and go back in the
film you know editing that film and
editing a film period when you're
teaching yourself that is really rough
on people that live with you
so you know why but I went in and
re-edited in the and I'm happy I did
that so that was the biggest work for me
and she should've mentioned off camera
there that the distributor had the movie
and it came back to you and said look
you need to readd at this they're
hinting around because I was always
asking we're gonna be able get this on
TV are we gonna get tucson pay-per-view
are we gonna be able to do this I would
always ask you know and they they would
say things well you know you should have
done this you should've done that I get
well let me do it then you know and I
did it it's so much better now so
knowing that not knowing these lessons
that you've now have gained from sort of
making this film and distributing this
film I know you said that now you're
working on a new action drama what what
sort of lessons have you learned that
you're now applying to this next project
well my distributor taught me that i
could write characters that type of
characters i like to write and put him
in a John your base type of film and I
listened to him and he was and I thank
him for that and so that the project i
wrote you know is an action drama like
you said and it's called the guide you
only talk about that yeah please do tell
us about the guy well I'd sent a script
to Steve Guttenberg and he passed on it
on a previous script and he said that he
wanted to do action adventure so I had
this being told to me and i also had my
distributor telling me that I need to
write something not so a Fellini type
weird type of which I think it's pretty
straightforward if you ask me if there's
just a few hallucinations and stuff in
there some trippy moments and quick to
that but I had all these people telling
me I need to do this so I did it you
know and
and it seemed to work out because it's
gotten me talking to a lot of people
about the new project and it has Steve
wanting to do the next project as the
lead you know as the lead okay and so
the guide you know is a set to go you
know almost were almost got a few other
things we got to put together you know
it's about as this X arena football
league player right and he's he joined
the Marines when he was younger because
he didn't have to didn't have a college
scholarships is in the marine reserves
right and his football career is coming
to an end and he's still in the reserves
you know and uh it's this football teams
keep folding you know Irene a football
those guys don't make a lot of money on
average is around 20 grand a year so at
the end of football his wife's pregnant
another baby is coming what am I gonna
do he joins full time right before nine
eleven and then he goes to war for 10
years and comes back all messed up in
the head ends up on the streets of
Hollywood and I don't tell the whole
movie but uh he gets a job as a tour
guide and some crazy things happen and
he has to do what eros do after he gets
the help he needs so it's a hero in need
of help is the film that's about a guy
kind amazing of rocky that it's not a
boxing movie but the character miles
Bowden is the lead he's kind of going
through a lot he's a good guy going
through a lot and he does the right
thing at the end and fights to get his
self dignity back and at the same time
helping Los Angeles
you